hi guys my name is mike gene i'm here
with my baby sienna who is
very excited for this hi i'm lindsay and
this is griffin
and he is about two years old
and today we're gonna watch something
thank you mama you got it
huh i love this video i've
i've seen this tick tock before this
baby's the cutest
[Music]
how do you say uh what's the magic word
please
did you like that one yeah did it make
you hungry yeah
yeah do you want a treat yeah yeah here
you go okay
there you go
and you disappear or you make an object
disappear and they think that it's gone
forever
well this is because they have no object
permanence
object permanence is basically going
down just gonna know what that is
even though it's hidden okay so let's
test this out my baby loves the remote
let's test it with this what's that baby
doing
where'd
[Music]
did you like that baby yeah is she so
cute
yeah yeah all right you see the remote
that is going to hide it
with the remote oh she found it
look at that baby
[Music]
look he's in charge of the of the
computer screen here
i love this
he's cooking that's right
[Music]
oh it's doubling up the cheese
you love casserole
[Music]
what do you think about this baby you
think shanna can cook
you know you want to watch the babies
again
yeah yes boo period that's my best
friend that's my best friend you're my
daughter
yes do it girl you got it yes boo period
poo
come on girl you got this girl remember
when channel was like that
oh my god sienna couldn't crawl and then
all of a sudden you just got up and ran
right here it's literally right here
girl just come right here and you got it
no cap come on yeah is that cute baby
is that a cute baby girl come on i'm
literally right here all you got to do
is take a step towards me and you're
right here like come on girl you so cute
like come on girl
oh my god i think it might actually work
i'm gonna start doing this like every
day what'd you think of that video
griffin
yeah what baby you just want to keep
watching are you
just like in a little bit of a tick tock
trance i think you are all right you
want to watch some more oh yeah
oh yeah okay story of the person that's
been going around to houses robbing your
door
yeah yeah some
robber is going around just stealing
people's donuts
are you going to people's houses and
stealing their donuts no
you seem guilty
[Music]
you're a superhero yeah what are your
powers you want to have a donut
yeah yeah we don't have any donuts right
now
and what do you get for a reward
i get to be a hero you would like to
have a donut yeah
okay okay like what kind of superhero
can i be
you can you can be
you are gonna have a purple car is that
a baby okay
what are you gonna do that's a cute baby
about the purple costume what are his
powers
um wow cute baby yeah
i love this story yeah because i don't
wanna ice good i don't really wanna ice
anybody but i guess
that would help if i just iced bad
people if he was an ice person he could
make popsicles
no what's my name what's my name
wonderbook
[Music]
what did you think of the videos it was
[Music]
good
one more and then all done
[Music]
you